if you're considering buying Hogwarts
Legacy whether with a pre-order before
launch or waiting until reviews hit here
are the top things you need to know
before you make that decision to buy
starting with the fact that we now have
confirmation Hogwarts Legacy will
include vrr support and a performance
mode that targets 60fps on both PS5 and
Xbox series X and S additionally we also
have the recommended PC specs across the
full range so we have the minimum specs
here on the left with the recommended
high quality specs on the right on the
next page here we have the Ultra 1440p
specs on the left and then the ultra 4K
specs on the right so if you're planning
to play this on the PC give it a good
look to make sure you can run at your
desired settings steam deck owners
you're in luck because the official WB
game support account on Twitter has in
fact confirmed that Hogwarts Legacy will
be steam deck verified at launch now are
there any other reasons you'd want to go
with one version over another well first
we should start off with when you can
actually play each one wasn't it
actually delayed again or something well
sort of it all depends on where you're
playing and which version you're playing
Hogwarts Legacy is releasing on PC PS5
PS4 Xbox series X and S Xbox One and
even the Nintendo switch so up first we
have PC PS5 and Xbox series X and S
players you'll get to play the standard
version of the game on Friday February
10th this version retails for 69.99 on
PS5 and Xbox whereas PC players can get
it for ten dollars cheaper at 59.99
however if you want to be the absolute
first in line to play there is a version
releasing on Tuesday February 7th that
is the deluxe version of the game again
for PS5 Xbox series Xs and PC this one
is ten dollars more than the standard
edition counterpart so 79 for the
consoles and 69.99 for the PC what else
are you getting in addition to that 72
hours early access well the deluxe
version also includes access to the dark
arts battle arena dark arts cosmetic set
and the thestral mount now what if you
want to take a wait and see approach and
just see if those Cosmetics are really
worth that extra ten dollars when it
comes to the battle arena and the
Cosmetics set and of course the with
astral Mount well even if you purchase
that standard edition that we talked
about you do have the option to purchase
an upgrade after the fact so you can get
the game check out reviews and see if
you actually think it's worth paying
that ten dollars to do it and then you
can add it on after the fact if you want
we did already get a very good look at
the dark arts battle arena in the most
recent gameplay showcase which you can
see some of that footage here and yet
they also confirmed there are two more
Arenas that everyone will have access to
unfortunately we have yet to see those
in action and to see how they will
compare to the dark arts Arena now oddly
the digital Deluxe includes a single
item that's not included in the physical
and that is the dark arts Garrison hat
not really sure what the deal with that
is maybe they just want to give you a
perk for going digital not sure now I
also want to say I'm not here to tell
you whether you should pre-order or you
should not that is totally up to you of
course you can pre-order all the way up
until the actual launch of the game so
hopefully there will be a chance to
check out early reviews or previews of
the game once folks start getting their
hands on the game which we've yet to
hear when exactly that's going to be if
you've been burned by pre-orders before
and you take the wait and see approach
trust me I get it no harm no foul so to
try and entice players to pre-order
though they are including a digital item
with any version of the game when you
pre-order and that is the Onyx
hippogriff Mount yes you'll be able to
ride standard Hypocrites in the game but
as far as we know this pre-order is the
only way you'll get to ride the Onyx one
that we see here as for the delay I
mentioned unfortunately players on last
gen you'll have to wait until April 4th
as that is when Hogwarts Legacy will
release on the PS4 and Xbox One and
finally there's the Nintendo switch
version which we'll release in the
summer on July 25th 2023. another
consideration you'll want to weigh in
your decision on which platform is the
timed exclusive content that's right
love it or hate it both the PS4 and PS5
versions include the haunted hogsmeat
shop quest which will remain exclusive
to the PlayStation platforms for a full
calendar year after that year is up we
assume that the PC Xbox and switch will
also get that haunted hogsmeade Quest
now if you pre-order on a PlayStation
platform you'll also get the Felix
Felice's potion recipe so again love it
or hate it just making sure you are
fully informed on all the editions of
the game now regardless of which version
you choose you'll have a range of
accessibility and difficulty options to
play the game how you want to play the
difficulty options even include a story
mode which is actually a tier lower than
the easy difficulty so this will be for
players who are purely there to
experience the story now if you are a
Harry Potter Super Fan Wizarding World
Fan Hogwarts Legacy man whatever you
want to call it there are even more
options for the super fans including a
252 page art book a strategy guide and a
collector's edition which at most places
is actually sold out now as far as the
art book goes you can get that just
about anywhere books are sold including
on Amazon I'll throw a link down in the
description below and we recently had a
sneak peek of this art book courtesy of
sci-fi and as a pretty die-hard Potter
fan myself I have to say it is looking
very impressive even though the price
tag is a little bit steep it's like 45
dollars last I checked but it certainly
seems like they are packing a lot of
content in that art book remains to be
seen on the strategy guide yet it is
much cheaper than in the art book so you
would assume as far as strategy guides
go you're going to get a basic strategy
guide there now the collector's edition
I mentioned it's sold out most places
now it was quite the disappointment for
many fans not necessarily for the items
included but really for the Steep 300
price tag if you are still interested in
that one and you're looking around
online to see if there's still any
available it does include everything
from the Deluxe plus a steel book The
Kelpie robe digital cosmetic and a
life-size plastic book with a wand that
hovers above it when plugged into a
power outlet now additionally for
longtime fans of the series there are
even people who are just discovering the
World of Harry Potter you can actually
get sorted right now for the game some
of you out there may remember the old
Pottermore website well now it's
officially known as wizardingworld.com
and you can set up a free account today
and then link it to your WB Games
account even better and even easier if
you already have an account over there
so what's the benefit here of linking
these two accounts well you'll have a
head start on the sorting and wand
ceremonies because both your house and
wand type will be brought over from The
Wizarding World site into Hogwarts
Legacy that's right if you've taken the
quiz before it'll all link up nicely if
you've never taken the quiz you can go
on sign up take it for free and link
your account the key of course is that
WB Games account so when you boot up
Hogwarts Legacy for the first time
you're going to log in with that account
and then have the option of bringing
your house in one keyword there option
maybe you're not satisfied with your
Wizarding World house and want no
worries as you'll have full veto power
when starting up the game so even if
your accounts are linked you can choose
to go against what the Wizarding World
site gave you so you might say well then
what's the point of linking them if I
may reject them anyway I would recommend
you go ahead and Link them because you
will unlock free in-game Cosmetics
including a beat skull mask and then
what I'm most excited about these house
fanatic rows which will automatically
match the house your playing is so it
can even change on subsequent
playthroughs so let's say first you want
to play through as a Slytherin and then
you go back as a Ravenclaw it's not like
you're going to be stuck with that
Slytherin robe you're gonna get the
Ravenclaw one as well pretty cool how
they managed to work that in what about
the Patronus well unfortunately that
will not be brought over into Hogwarts
Legacy and it remains to be seen if
we'll even be using the patronum charm
at all in the game we did see Dementors
in the original reveal trailer and they
also make an appearance on the deluxe
cover of the game however we haven't
seen them in quite some time so it
remains to be seen if they're going to
be in the game at all despite us being
so close to launch there are still a few
misconceptions that I see Pop Up from
time to time online so I'll try and
clear up a few of them quickly here
first the game it's not an MMO it is a
single player open world action RPG no
multiplayer either when it comes to
quidditch no not happening at least in
terms of playable quidditch of course
quidditch is going to be part of the
world we may even see people playing
quidditch in the game but as far as our
character being able to play know that
it's been confirmed not happening
they've also confirmed no Wizards chests
or gobstones although it's possible we
could see some other mini games we just
don't really know what they are yet
unless of course you've looked at the
trophy list and then you might have an
idea about at least one of them that
being said there are some inclusions
that fans never expected like a fully
customizable room of requirement in
addition to multiple bavariums where you
can care for Magical beasts that you've
rescued from poachers I mean this one
here just really excites me I never
expected anything like this level of
customization here in the room of
requirement I mean this is taking me
back to an animal crossing release and
I'm just sitting there decorating my
house it truly looks like we were going
to be able to make this area our own as
for other customization you will be able
to create your character at the start of
the game and while it doesn't appear to
be an incredibly deep character creator
there will be quite a few options to
give your witch or wizard a unique look
that hopefully suits you the hairstyles
in particular though are incredibly well
done as far as the story goes it has
been kept fairly quiet but we do know
that our character starts their journey
in The Wizarding World with a bit of
fanfare after having survived something
of significance it seems likely that
it's connected to our unique ability to
perceive and master ancient magic now
this whole idea of ancient magic is a
mechanic that acts both as a plot device
and an actual gameplay mechanic in the
form of this ancient magic meter believe
it or not this meter gives you the
ability to perform incredibly powerful
attacks like this lightning strike here
or even turning your enemies into a
chicken what about other spells well
guess what we will have the option to
learn the three unforgivable versus
crucio Avada Kedavra and Imperial have
all been confirmed regardless of whether
you purchased that dark arts battle
arena just want to be very clear about
that now it does remain to be seen what
sort of consequences we'll face if we
choose to use this dark magic how will
it impact our character in the world
around us now unlike Harry we'll start
our journey in Hogwarts as a fifth year
again the reason for this is likely tied
to ancient magic in our character's
connection to it we are set to meet some
familiar faces though even though the
game takes place in the late 1800s
ghosts like nearly headless Nick the fat
Friar and even peeps the Poltergeist are
all set to make an appearance there's
even a professor Weasley a Gryffindor
who's our Deputy head mistress and
professor of transfiguration in Hogwarts
Legacy now if you still have questions
about Hogwarts like see let me know in
the comments below and I'll try to do my
best and answer them guys we are going
to have so much Hogwarts Legacy content
leading up to and after launch so if you
want to make sure you don't miss
anything be sure to subscribe and turn
on the notification Bell before you go
as for questions you may be wondering
about the game spells and how they're
gonna work in combat that's one thing
the previous game games have never quite
mastered well it just so happens I have
the perfect video for you and I'm going
to link it here on the left side of your
screen now as always thank you all so
much for watching I'll talk to you again
soon